there's so many creators and so many
influencers and how can this sustain I
think more marketing money will go into
people and less to television less to
outdoor my big argument for 10 years is
that the long tale of influencers and
creators is much longer than people
realize that there's many 15-year-olds
right now who are going to make a
decision in 5 years do I want to make
$40,000 a year being a Creator or do I
want to be $40,000 a year being an
accountant and they're going to choose a
Creator cuz they're going to talk about
football or fashion or or whatever
they're passionate about so I think
we're actually just in the beginning it
seems like almost every year we have a
new trend like a few a couple years ago
it was in a you were a big Enthusiast of
it uh then it was a metaverse and now
everyone's talking about AI yes and uh a
lot of a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of
investors are uh getting into the hyp
train there's a lot of noise a lot of
fear of missing out so my question to
you is how can uh this Founders or even
investors they can uh seize the
opportunities with these Trends these
new technologies but do it right not
rushing into it and maybe doing itong
doing it wrong you know this is the way
it's been since the internet hit scale
in the late '90s there's always a trend
blogging social networks iPhone apps you
know there's always going to be Trends
because technology is moving very fast
now and you know when I invested in
Facebook and Twitter there was 800 other
social networks that you could have
invested in right um Orchid was big here
I don't have to remind you that that was
trying to make it in the US so I think
that the thing with AI or with nfts the
blockchain the things that are going to
come in the future that we can't even
think of right now it's always the same
game which is you have to find the
operators the
founders that you have to find the
founders The Operators that actually can
execute 98 99% of these businesses go
out of business you know 99% of iPhone
apps that tried to be Instagram didn't
end up being Instagram and so this is a
movie that I've seen 100 times and so
99% of the AI startups will fail and the
way you can be good at it or capitalize
is by making the right decision on the
individual person who's operating the
business the thesis exists the
blockchain will be important AI will be
important these things will exist but
from an investing startup standpoint a
very small percentage succeeds the
problem is the popular culture doesn't
realize how risky it is most Founders
think they're just going to be an
entrepreneur and a Founder that's going
to work and so you know I think nothing
has changed in that question the big
opportunities change there will be
Monumental businesses built for
Maya it's just going to be less than 1%
there was 700 startups that tried to win
search Yahoo won it first Google won it
second those are the big companies so I
don't think every game is a winner takes
all look at social networks Snapchat's a
viable business Pinterest is a viable
business you know Tik Tok and Instagram
and Twitter X so there can be 3 four 5 6
seven b and then there's smaller
businesses there's a lot of platforms we
don't talk about that are smaller that
have successful businesses they're just
not a trillion dollars so there'll be
hundreds of thousands of viable AI
businesses most most will be small um
but there will be enormous amount of
money lost in investing because that's
the nature of venture capital they
invest in 40 50 60 things and usually
one or two is what succeed for them hi
Gary huge thank you thank you for your
time for us which was so my question is
uh you are known for creating content
and I want to know what device will you
g to someone who when starting to create
content like the ultimate device I think
the ultimate advice for Content creation
is to talk about either one of two
things something that you really know
you are genuinely someone who is
knowledgeable about a subject matter
or something that you're a huge
Enthusiast in something that you're very
passionate about you may not know
everything about fashion but you might
think about it 24 hours a day and so you
can make content about that or like when
I grew up and I started content the
place I went to was wine because it was
the thing I knew the most I knew the
most about it and so I knew I could make
a lot of content so I think the
authenticity of knowledge or passion
are the foundational pieces the ultimate
advice to being good at content too many
people do content wanting to be famous
too many people do content wanting to
make money too many people do content
thinking they have to do what's
trending and those are all vulnerable
Frameworks for big success the only
things that really pull it off are
Talent OR passion and I think that's
what you be focused on you're
welcome I think the other thing that I
didn't mention is people don't realize
how much skill is required to be a good
content creator how much understanding
of the math around the
art what do the first 3 seconds look
like in your video what time do you post
how many words do you use what's the
thumbnail look like there's a lot of
skill in content creation and I think
people misunderstand that hi
NY I ask please please excuse
me thank
you to me the long taale the micro
business like I talked about with AI
there'll be hundreds of small is
probably the thing I'm more passionate
about than the big businesses or the big
players you know my advice is to double
down on what got them there A lot of
times small micro
influencers they they get confused once
they start getting some traction they
think they have to do something
different now I have to act different
when you start getting traction the key
is actually to double down on what got
you there so I would say first focus on
knowing what you're doing doing more of
it but the biggest thing that I think
small Niche operators creators should be
doing is becoming more knowledgeable
about the platforms maybe they're just
winning on YouTube shorts maybe they're
just winning on Tik Tok but there's
LinkedIn there's Twitter there's snap
there's so many more platforms and that
can help them grow too many of those
individuals focus on one or two
platforms right we saw 5 years ago
people that one on Instagram they were
hesitant to go on Tik Tok and that hurt
their growth so spreading to more places
where they produce content would be my
number one piece of
advice my friend how do you see the
future of Creator economy do you see
consolidation do you see a new TV kind
of stuff like put together a huge amount
of creat how do you see that I no I
actually think more expansion I think
what we're feeling now is actually going
to grow dramatically back to the last
question my big argument for 10 years is
that the long tale of influencers and
creators is much longer than people
realize that there's many 15-year-olds
right now who are going to make a
decision in 5 years do I want to make
$40,000 a year being a Creator or do I
want to be $40,000 a year being an
accountant and they're going to choose a
Creator cuz they're going to talk about
football or fashion or wine or whatever
their passion about so I think we're
actually just in the beginning I know a
lot of people think that there's so many
creators and so many influencers and how
can this sustain I think more marketing
money will go into people and less to
television less to outdoor less and that
will go but the but not everyone's going
to make a million dollars but do you see
them getting together to create
NWS probably not you know I mean you
know I'm not so sure that yeah sure are
some but not at scale first of all the
biggest problem with that is
personalities it's hard for five or six
people to agree on something you know um
and you know the reality is the networks
are is the
internet you know so the reality is the
distribution is commoditized anyone can
get it sure getting together creates
some more hype houses those kind of
things but I don't I think that's a
small part of the overall ecosystem and
I think will continue to be that
way very
good the
news thank you I just wanted to ask
about like how do you of switching and
educa a to go from
consing to which difficult face text to
YouTube or Tik Tok anytime to your point
the reason it may be difficult is it
might not be in the DNA of the news to
be good at
video when you have a newsletter it's
actually very easy to get people to
video because you have attention and
they just have to click and watch I
don't believe it's hard to get people
from there are very few people on Earth
that only read text they read text and
they watch video my my concern my
concern when I hear that from you is is
the organization good at video many
organizations are better at video than
they are at text better at text than
they are at audio better at audio than
they are at text so the the question
there is it's not hard to take people's
attention from a newsletter to video
I've seen it a hundred times around the
world it just might not be the thing
that the organization is great at
yet right maybe not yet maybe needs to
bring a different style of video
different talents internally but that to
me there is no an audience isn't like oh
I only look at the news the news
newsletter for text I don't want to get
video from them if you give them good
video they will click it and they will
watch it and they will
stay picking up question about you said
about the long tail yes um so if the the
content more
decentralized uh where are the big
opportunities is like uh content
platforms uh Creator tools because a lot
of people want to get get into the
market and make money out of it so what
do you see in the future about the
concerning about this decentralization
of concept all three of the things that
you're thinking about are all viable you
can be a human that decides to be a
content creator that's a business you
could be a human as a more of a tech
engineer and you can create the tools
for the creators or you can create the
next platform you know Tik Tok not the
end of the social network Evolution just
like Facebook wasn't just like Twitter
wasn't just like Snapchat wasn't like
there every 3 to 5 to 7 to 10 years
something will come along and that's
assuming that the phone continues to be
the remote control of Our Lives what is
absolutely looming is the metaverse it's
looming the hype has been here but it's
not real yet but I don't think anybody
sitting in this room doesn't think in
the next 30 Years that people are going
to do
virtual reality we just have to wait you
know just like the phone it took a while
for the phone and its development to
become what it is today but as long as
the phone is the primary device of
attention in our society there's always
the opportunity for a new Social Network
the internet is unlimited so the tail
has to go long for distribution but but
creating SAS businesses for tools
creating platforms or being the content
producer are all three viable plays for
the long term for the people that Tred
to get in and make money you just have
to be self-aware of which one of those
are you more likely to be good
at all right with this we finish the
session so thank you very much thank you
very much we looking forward to seeing
you on stage thank you very
much thank
[Music]
you